Action, how are you,
my friend?
-I'm amazing.
Couldn't feel better.
I could,
but let me not complain.
-You are coming to us
live from a gym.
You've dropped some weight
You've shaved your head.
You're feeling good?
-Yeah.
Well, let me excuse you
a second.
This is a fitness institute.
-[ Laughs ]
-And, yeah, I dropped
a little bit of weight, man.
I was a disgusting,
despicable animal.
And now I'm feeling
a lot better about myself.
-Can I get a picture
for my kids?
-Yeah, of course, hold on.
Let's take a picture.
Pardon me, hold on.
-Oh, my gosh.
Will you stay 6 feet away
from whoever you're taking
a picture with?
-I'm going to.
Go ahead.
-All right.
[ Laughs ]
Action, you cannot be safe
when you're in a gymnasium
or a fitness institution.
-We've all been tested.
-All right, good.
You gotta wipe everything down
-Everything is all good.
Trust me.
That was the first time
I've actually talked to anybod
in six months.
-And that guy did not --
Is that the normal demographic
of your stealthy fan base?
He looked a little bit older
-Listen, I touch many hearts
[ Both laugh ]
-You know, usually --
Usually when you
come on the show,
we eat some food together.
We've had octopus,
some baked ziti.
You were kind enough to send m
some of your new ice cream
This is ice cream you made
with the good people
at Morgenstern's, yeah?
-That's right.
My guy Nick Morgenstern.
That right there is --
Well, I'm putting out
a new album called
"Only for Dolphins."
And I'm sure trying to hit
every single sense
of the human accessibility -
flavor, sight...
ear, touch, uh...
humanity.
[ Both laugh ]
-Wait. Was --
Was the third one "hear"?
-Yeah, hear.
[ Both laugh ]
So I'm just trying
to touch everybody's heart
with different aspects,
and that right there is
a charred guava marshmallo
tres leches.
Which is inspired by my
indigenous Colombian Queen
whom I'm in love with very much,
who we brought a beautiful
baby boy into this world with.
-That's fantastic.
How old is your baby boy?
-He just turned 8 months.
-8 months.
How's he doing?
-He's great.
Last month, it was too early
but now I can literally play him
Turkish prog rock
because he can fully understan
the progressions
at this point
in the juncture of life.
Last month, no.
-7 months is too early
for Turkish prog rock.
-Way too early.
-But then 8 months, fine.
-Well, he showed me signs.
He showed me signs
that he wanted --
he needed this in his life
-[ Laughs ]
It should be noted that
"For Dolphin Only"
is also gonna be the name
of your new album, yeah?
-Yeah.
Well, you can say it
"For Dolphin Only,"
"Only for Dolphins,"
"Dolphins Only For."
It's really however you feel
because --
-Thank you.
-Yeah, 'cause you're a dolphin
and I know you understand it
and this is for people
who understand it as well as
amphibians and reptiles
and different types of species
It's for all species, really
-When is your album
gonna be out?
-I'm hoping
the beginning of September
I don't even know when that is
'cause I don't even know
what the hell today is.
It's been a blur.
This has been a mess.
So, I just know it's a day
-Hey, this new season of
"[Bleep] That's Delicious"..
-Oh, yeah.
-...one of the nice things
about watching it is remembering
a time where you could trave
and eat food and be social
And one of the places
that I think maybe has
a bad reputation for food
that is maybe not deserved
according to you, is Dublin.
You had a great time in Dublin
-Man, what a hidden gem
Dublin is.
That is a phenomenal place
And very eclectic, surprisingly.
We found the best
of probably everything
that there is to find in Dublin.
Man, Jamaican, Irish,
Scottish mixtures.
Crazy, just --
Mexican food.
Classic, you know, Irish cuisine
and just a mixture of everything
in one place with some
progressive wine bars
and tremendous gastronomy
situations in these little old
like, hollowed-out
train stations.
It's just very cool-looking.
And then right across the way,
you could get the best pin
in town,
have a nice conversation
with some older men
who use Instagram...
[ Both laugh ]
...that refuse to follow you
I'll be like,
"Yo, come on, follow us, man
Why are you not following us?"
"No, I don't want to."